the lower stances the timing
beginner training just like when we do
the that great follower you sit back in
town on a forward roll those there
beginner techniques okay
that's to get you heading in the right
direction and the same goes with this
and Canton I cannot block this it's not
Aikido do you understand
so we use that as the beginner technique
to learn the geometry but that would be
a clash right all right meeting his
energy with my energy what I'm going to
do is boom
attack his Suba through the good spot of
his cut okay so if you're with your
hakama we have to move away from this
okay and it is a most when you can
because that's a much easier kami right
because he has time it's ready to go
okay who can't do that he's got to get
to you Kimi with me attack him
do you understand so start picking it up
and try to sophisticate your heart good
thank you so he's going to go slow and
you'll see how I'm going to absorb to
free my weapon okay yeah very much like
we're doing Nico
right that's where it's us okay I am
going to disappear I'm gonna make that
contention point disappear so that's
happening on the first one to see boom
three in my sword is free
three it clean so just like Nikki oh I
am be sensitive in Iowa I already feel
the tension easy
same thing here first love I feel his
weight I felt that so that's telling me
here oh I feel that you see that right
there
there's his weight is pushing on me now
so I feel it I yield to him he goes boom
just a simple deviation and deflection
Hey
because of my moves because of one group
tour I'm pushing doing his Center he has
to respond he has to take the cameras do
you understand that
so it's given me my reaction time that I
that I need to honor everyone so the
first one I pushed through a Center he
comes around I pushed through the center
and here he didn't do anything to you
he just deviated so he he's trying to
hit me on the happy so when I come in
that's when he should his source should
be cutting off my my face okay so it's
not it's not going to be one two and
then no okay this is go slow but if you
want that timing okay and it's because
you're getting checked out you're
getting checked out because you're not
neutralizing via twisting the drop okay
so let's assume
that is doing that you're gonna go get
you're gonna feel yen that's what he was
using you're gonna feel a lot again okay
so you've been kind of think of it as
starting all over again the same way
that I have this say GaN where you go
bulls
hold pull this unit I'm gonna go back to
that do you understand till I see his
hands play won't see and he went up so
I'm bringing my stay going up okay let's
do it on the other side and that will
kind of almost happen naturally because
you were keeping contact with his weapon
as long as possible you see that and
then I'm going to attack the source
again that's that's what's right there
so is that what I'm going to do boom
boom and I'll attack his center again
through the
the point is to kill this work she got
hit here yes right gets
[Applause]